welcome everybody i'm the fresh prince
of dead air
you are watching the ethan klein
experience
um with well it's also the ela client
experience
so i shouldn't get too egotistical over
here
but today we have with us a very highly
coveted guest
one who many of us have probably
well let me just say this zach
zack has uh how do i say this without
getting demonetized
[ __ ] many times dude
yeah you had to go there well
yeah he's actually very starstruck right
now zach
yeah oh is he really yes i'm extremely
my heart sank zach all right calm down
all right anyway today's episode is
sponsored by liquid iv and honey
bell delphine thank you for joining us
how are you today
i'm really good thank you thank you for
having me on
and i really appreciate the little
poster thing at the back
and the octopus 10 out of 10. yeah well
then
that octopus is actually a family
favorite the dogs love it the kid loves
it everybody loves the octopus
yeah ela is also all kawaii dao
so yeah and also actually
bel dolphin is going to be my costume
too for halloween
wow no that is going to be cursed
so tell me are you you describe yourself
online as a kitty
girl is that what does that mean
oh i meant belle sorry belle you
describe yourself as a kitty girl what
does that mean
even you can't start off the podcast by
mixing me up with yeah well she's in a
kitty outfit i mean give me a break
um a kitty girl well like what is a
kitty girl or like what
okay what is a kitty girl um well an
anime there's this whole like necro girl
thing which is uh just like a girl with
cat ears and a tail like a cross between
a cat and a girl
and i think it's a just like a cute
a cute character that a girl can be and
i've always liked the
whole look of like the cat ears i've
always thought it was really cute i wish
they were more acceptable to just wear
out in public
but i tried that
yeah it's not so do you so when you
cruise
around outside are you kind of just like
looking normal yeah it depends
like sometimes i'll dress up for an
occasion if i'm like
meeting up with friends or i mean before
covert going
for like a restaurant or something like
that then yeah like dress up and look
nice and wear skirts and all
things like that but when i'm just going
out my everyday attire is just like
hoodie beanie leggings trainers
no pink no kitty ears do you get
recognized or do people not recognize
you without all the
the kitty girl attire i see i would have
thought no one
would have recognized me when i'm like
just
like beanie hoodie and stuff like this
but
i have gotten recognized a few times and
it's always very
strange to navigate because i'm like
going out with the mindset that like
no one's gonna know who like recognize
me so when i do it's always like oh
like it's always like a surprise and
it's always
at the root always at the weirdest
places oh yeah
so what is it like to meet your fans are
they kind of like odd dudes or have you
ever had odd
interaction because i can imagine zach
coming up to you i would be freaked out
if a dude likes that okay
jesus christ listen to zach he's
speechless take it easy over there
come on she's a human being
yeah have you ever had any weird
interactions with the fans
honestly it's always usually kind of
awkward because
the people who always come up to me are
usually quite young so if there's
there's this really awkwardness of being
like
i can't i can't um deal with this
situation because first off i don't even
want you to know i exist
right where are your parents
wow well it's just it's just
that's a little awkward little kids
because like uh
yeah i don't necessarily wouldn't want
to know that you're talking like under
18 i'm assuming yeah
yeah like like 15 oh boy
yeah you don't want that age you don't
want that attention
what i usually say is i just say it's
not
me and then they're usually like oh okay
oh really
you can get away with that interesting
yeah yeah yeah why would i say
they're 15 they're idiots yeah what is
really good is like say like haha
no i just look a lot like her you know i
get that all the time
i just look like her and then people are
usually like oh
okay and then they just carry on
and so i find that interesting that
you're in a way not
why is it that you don't want to be
recognized in public like why is it that
you
you want that separation for yourself
um well i just don't really like
attention
that much like um in real life i really
like to
i mean i segment everything like all
parts of my life i segment it so
i've got family friends work real life
and then you know but even with friends
i'm not really like me me me look at me
and things like this but
on the internet i am like that so it's
very
it's so different so in real life i
don't really like
i wouldn't like to be like
recognized i just wouldn't like it i
just really like it i like
i'm so in my own zone like when i'm out
in public and i'm going shopping or
something i'm just like right
i need eggs i need bacon i need all
these things i'm just like
this i'm not thinking about um hello i
am bill delphine
nice to meet you sort of thing so bell
how did you get into
this line of of uh per like this
profession is this some
kind of something you've always wanted
to do how did you land on this
um i've always been doing well bef
before i
got into the more adult side of things i
always liked things like fashion and i
was more into it back then
i was always into like kawaii fashion
and things like this
so i basically just took photos of
myself
uploaded them on facebook and kind of
gained like a very
very small following on that and then
what kind of photos were you uploading
just
just kawaii like cute little skirts and
crop tops and things like this
nothing uh lewd um
and then i started following
older girls who were doing leader things
and i just thought that was really cool
at the time and
i was still like young at the time so
obviously i didn't do i waited until
i was 18 and then six months into being
18
i think that's when i was kind of like
this is something that i'm gonna do
for myself now and just experiment with
it and see how it kind of goes
started a patron then and yeah just kind
of went from there
you know you seem to have like such a
strategic approach to it
is that is am i observing that right
because like you have all these
you're really incredible at like
promoting yourself and your brand i have
to say you're kind of a genius when it
comes to that
is that like
is that intentional like how do you
think about all that stuff are you have
you always been strategically minded
like how
ahead of time do you plan these kind of
like the bathwater girl
and the the uh you know
yeah the mystery boxes are insane of
course then
you know they're getting and fight or
you you uh
your hamster got stolen all this i guess
i can ask you about each individually
but yeah
yeah well basically what happened was
so when i was 18 and a half and i
started doing all this stuff
straight away i i thought about it
because i had to go into it in a work
mind frame because before that i was
babysitting that's how i was getting my
money
and i i just i had one bad
really bad night babysitting and after
that night i was like i am never what
happened
yeah i want to know what happened dude
it was so
it changed your life look at it it was
the best night of your life i'm
curious i had one really bad one too i'm
curious what happened to you
so how i got all the all the people
where they were just all people in my
neighborhood i made little leaflets and
i was like you know
babysitting for six pounds 50 an hour
and i just handed them out to all my
neighbors
and then i got like loads of of these
neighbors contacting me being like
oh you know i'd like you for this day
this day this day so eventually it
became a job out of the blue
and i had this one regular mum who had
two kids
and they were very sweet um
so i would babysit them for them often
and then i started to realize um
i'm trying to think of a nice way to
like put it um
i think they they had a autism or
asperger's or something like this
they got quite violent and um
i didn't know how to deal with this
right but i i just
dealt with it the best i could um and
then so she ordered me for one night it
was meant to be three hours i was like
absolutely fine
funny story this was when the exact day
donald trump was announced that he was
president
so i was watching the elections as this
happened
so i was i was there three hours goes by
she's still not here
she's uh that's fine they always go
overtime
parents always go overtime so i was like
that's fine
four hours go by still not here that
that's fine
long story short she was 16 hours late
the thing is i was i was expecting her
to come back so i stayed awake
this whole time i was just and i was
just watching the elections happen
being like i'm so so tired but even
the night just got worse and worse
because the kids woke up
and they were like bashing like each
other and stuff it was just terrible
it was terrible sounds like a bad acid
trip 16 hours
it was it was so bad and the cheek of it
all right
was when the mom came back she was like
i'm sorry i just fell asleep at the
place
and usually usually parents like
they'll tip like i don't know two pounds
or three pounds or something just to
like because you know if you're paying
17 pounds you're rounded up to 20
or something like this she paid me to
the pence
to the to the pens and i was just like
i have suffered tonight i have
suffered um and then it was just
that on top of other things i just i'm
not babysitting again
that's it so then yeah i got into
remodeling
there you go i mean it was you know
[Laughter]
although i have to assume you're you're
probably being compensated
a little bit more than six pounds per
hour nowadays
i mean that's the crazy thing about the
internet is um
it just it took me back being able to
even make
money out of these things because i was
getting free clothes from
like kawaii companies and i was like
this is amazing
i'm getting free clothes to wear them
and i would buy them anyway this is
amazing
so when i actually started getting paid
for posting photos i was like
this is mental this is crazy
um but basically what happened was i
started so i started doing this adult
posting online
and one video went really big at the
time
it was the ahigao face that i did and
it it got biggs and then i was like okay
i'm gaining some followers i need to
take advantage of this and this is the
this is when the spark sort of went for
me i was like
i've got something that could be from
this
so what i
what i did from this point is i was like
i need to figure out a way
for people to be interested in me i've
got the taking cute pictures and stuff
but that's not gonna really
do it there's so many cute girls on the
internet i need to do something
that will make people even
say negative things about me or just
just have a conversation having a
conversation
is how you propel things on the internet
is people
responding to it and sharing it so i
decided to do
weird things in the combination as well
as being sexy like
i'll be sexy and i'll be like cracking
an egg in my mouth or something
and then people will share that be like
what the [ __ ] this girl's so
weird and quirky or whatever
yeah but but i'll also put my image out
there
so i just started playing on this doing
with stuff while
trying to be sexy
you're a genius i have to say that is
genuine i gotta say i mean
you that's very smart you know
and that's how you've always come across
our desk because i think that's a really
good observation there's plenty of cute
girls on the internet
right but when you see something and
you're like what the [ __ ]
is this that's when you really share it
um yeah zach which was the first
when was the first time you saw belle
zack
uh when we first uh talked about her
um i think it was the um what was it the
bathroom water bath water
yeah it was the bathroom the bath water
was so
freaking viral it was so viral that we
were shocked to even hear
howard stern talk about it on his show
that was
for us like jesus that just went like
all over the world
and all over all ages yeah because
howard is like
the peak of the pyramid not just in like
who he is but
like if an internet meme reaches that
level yeah
that's insane culture then
it's everywhere yeah well
was that your biggest like viral moment
that i think that blew us all away
yeah so tell me about the bathwater
story how did you
first of all did you bathe in all the
water you sold tell the truth
now yes okay i believe i did
yes i did it was the whole fun of it
and so tell me did you pee or fart in
the water or anything like that
i mean i think i spat in some of the
jars right
right that's good excellent yeah
do you normally pay in the shower oh
good question ela
um no i don't think so
i think so you never pee in the shower
is that is it weird
no in the shower no i think it's weird
not to pee in the shower
frankly or you just want to make me feel
okay no you i'm
telling you everybody i know pee's in
the shower
you should try it so well first before
we move on to the
the bathware thing the hi the a hegel
face am i saying that right
i think it's angel are we go ah
oh
well that's like a uh it's like a hentai
thing right
yeah yeah it's properly uh it's it's a
face
that they draw in hentai of the the
orgasm face
that's what they can you do it first can
i see what it looks like oh my god
i hate you know what you know what that
was the worst thing right
because you know ian i met me at the
pornhub event yeah yeah
yeah so at the pornhub events i was
so nervous right and then i was watching
the show
everything was great i was fine just sat
there watching not being a part of it
and then someone's like you know you got
to come up upstairs
and then they were like asa akira is
going to interview you and you're going
to be
you know they're going to video you and
you're just going to sit next to assa
akira
and she's going to ask you a couple of
questions and i was like oh
uh okay what questions are they gonna
ask me
um they were like oh they're gonna ask
you to do the face and i was like
please please for the love of god don't
make me
like because the because the face it's
actually quite hard to do
really a few times because it's really
easy to just
i mean it looks dumb anyway but it's
really easy to look dumb dumb
so yeah that was that was really bad
your bread and butter you don't want to
do a shitty
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's easy to look very dumb doing it yes
it's such a dumb face it is a dumb face
and i don't want to like
look very dumb so i tried it once and
people i always get the meme treatment
but it's like you look at your nose
right you cross your eyes and you just
stick out your tongue so it's like i
know you look up can you try to join the
daddy probably not it
you try dila you're i don't even know
what i don't i'm not
cross your eyes look up stick out your
tongue that looks like you're dead
try smiling while doing it like smiling
oh don't look dead right
no don't do that okay is that good
can i do an only fans now
you're not at the dentist it's like
you're trying to show us
all your teeth no cavities no cow dude
see that's what i'm worried i'll look
like when you guys ask me i'll be like
yeah sure and then do that
i get it so do you watch hentai i'm
curious
how did you discover you do is that your
preferred uh
category of pornography
no but there is a lot of pluses from
hentai i mean hentai is basically
the perfect pawn right it's everything
done perfectly the faces are perfect the
um
the boobs are perfect everything about
it is super
well done and ass very aesthetic
so i i like watching watching it for
i mean to get off to it obviously as
well but because it looks and it looks
really good as well but i think
casually probably no ah
well let me ask you this the tentacles
is that part of
like is that like a a rare offshoot of
hentai or is that like mainstream hentai
the tentacles
like do you enjoy the technical thing
it's very much
linked with hentai but i don't think
it's that common
right i don't think it's that common i
mean it's
i think it's just heavily linked like oh
hentai tentacles and obviously that is
tentacle hentai
but i don't think it's you know there's
so much stuff there's so much stuff
it pretty much hentai covers every
single category right
so that's i guess that's one thing why
people want to do because
sometimes porn can be very very similar
you know it's just but it doesn't cover
the whole range
i've heard one girl say she watched
hentai because she knows that
there's no victims because sometimes
with porn you never know like
what's really if there's like a story
going on back there so it's like
guilt-free for her i don't know
yeah so what is your favorite category
of porn zach was wondering
um yeah
calm down dude i said i'd ask her you
don't have to [ __ ]
chime in this is so embarrassing i feel
like it's
come on i will
okay but don't get like you can't have
like a certain type of opinion on me
this is just
tell me the truth um
probably i mean it's quite normal
gangbang
oh wow yeah round of applause
for belle beautiful
excellent yeah i mean it's great
it's great no complaints i'm thank you
once again i love the answer
have you visited blocked
that website's crazy yeah do you want
did you ever get into that one or is
that too because you would actually
haven't you haven't i have seen many
many fighter shots pictures of me yeah
yeah you might
actually be a perfect candidate so would
you ever
oh i gotta clap again for the gang bang
answer
come on give me that we love it i can't
wait tomorrow to see
like his favorite porn genre
is gangbang that's so awesome
yeah um are you as sexual a person
like as you portray yourself or do you
ham it up for the only fans you know
i am like i've always been um
i've always been see it's it's so weird
because i've always been like that one
freak at the sleepover that was like oh
we should play truth or dare
and like like oh like we should do it
where like
i'm the guy and like you're the girl and
then we're just meeting each other for
the first time and then we kiss
and stuff and i've always just been
interested in life like speaking about
it and think
you know it's just it's fun and it's
naughty and it's underground and it's
kind of like oh
should we be talking about this or
should we not it's just
it's just um it's fun
i think it's great i think that's i
think it's your career path
is is uh perfect um do you
i had a question i forgot it well i kind
of want it kind of makes me wonder about
your
and i don't know how much you want to
talk about it but like you're up
bringing
those were your parents kind of open
about this stuff or
are they okay with it now are they
conservative or like
is it like a rebellious thing or is it
all good in your family like the
you know what i mean are they embracing
of it um
see i come from a very conservative
family
like super religious i mean
i've got like family in the church
and they've it's always kind of been
that way but the thing is
because my grandparents were so heavily
associated with the church
they had um you know my mum
and my mom was a you know she was the
rebel kid so
i was the kid from the rebel kid
but but i i've still been associated so
much with uh
you know conservative upbringing um
so i think i always i always kind of
i've always been very independent
and i've always kind of found out things
that i've liked i mean i was
practically raised on the internet i
think everyone from our generation
well my generation or whatever was um
like every day after school i'd go on
the internet and i was kind of making my
own person
by choosing what i wanted to view online
and
i guess i kind of molded myself and my
interest around what i saw
and i think that's kind of where all my
interests kind of came from is the
messed out part of
the the internet that i was looking at
let me ask you this because i remember
you did this
you you were like signing bibles right
for yeah
so did that upset your family something
like that
or do they not even know about it um
they don't know
really do you think it would have
happened
i see with the bible even i was
conflicted about it because
the premise of the bible me signing the
bible was like what
self-obsessed person could sell the
bible
and add price to it just because of
their own signature and i was like
that is such an arrogant thing to do and
i was like
oh should i do it or should i not i
don't know because
i i don't want to come across like i
disrespect christianity because it was
such a big part of my upbringing
and still is a part of me today um
but i just i just did it because i i
just
all of the ideas that kind of
get get big make me feel a little bit
weird about it it's like bath water oh
like that's kind of that's kind of weird
or like should i play
about like me getting arrested like oh
should i or should i not it's always
these things that make me question my
decision
whether i should or should not do it i
usually push myself to do it
but those are the big ones you know
that's funny we have a similar kind of
feeling when we would go out and make
videos
yeah like vape nation for example before
we go out and shoot that i would always
go
i always get this feeling like is this
so dumb that we should
bother and then we go oh we should
definitely do it yeah
yeah at some point we learned that
whenever we have that feeling
we're like that's probably going to be
good yes yeah
yep i think that's a very very accurate
thing
so what does your mom think though she
she's down she's accepting
with the whole thing or do you guys have
do you guys have friction
um i remember when i first started doing
it
we had one conversation about it and
i basically said cause i'm i'm i
i think the worst thing ever is getting
the feeling of getting exposed like the
feeling of like your parent coming to
you and being like
i found this explain so i wanted to cut
that immediately
i've heard other girls having this
problem with their family and it's
always worse when they find out
it's always worse never do it never lie
never try and hide it
because they'll find it and then trust
me they'll find it
so i i went to her and i said hey this
is what i'm doing
um it's going pretty well i'm gonna
continue doing it
and then she asks you know is it porn
and i said
it's not porn it's it's um
it's erotic photography yes
come on mom
well it's the difference when i was a
kid they would say it's the difference
between like playboy and hustler i don't
know if that means anything
to you but yeah adult photography versus
like hardcore porn
you know yeah so does that mean you're
not gonna be ever doing hardcore porn
uh no it doesn't doesn't mean that i
might
yeah i think i might
zach how do you feel about that god
bless
i can't wait
well you know you know everyone's
waiting for that though i'm just saying
in the community
and then uh go ahead you had a question
so that conversation basically
was it and and your mom
uh she i mean she's really really okay
with it because i'm she
when she was younger she kind of did um
modeling and photography and things like
that
and so she kind of understands yeah
i mean she did some kind of you know
loot things
nowhere near what i'm doing but still
like you know how photography kind of
yeah no yeah um
so i guess that kind of helped her
understand a little bit
and she's really fine with it she's fine
yeah that's awesome yeah
you've joked about not having a dad is
that true
or do you have a dad well i mean i have
a dad
technically um
but
it's a tricky one that because i mean i
joke about
the fact that he disowned me
because you know oh like i didn't have a
dad haha that's funny and i've joked
about like
you know be him being so ashamed of me
and things like that
but in reality i disowned him so
oh are you comfortable talking about
that or is that like something you don't
want to discuss
i'm very curious because you mentioned
it in your videos and your art and stuff
about being
fatherless um he's
just a huge [ __ ] such a huge [ __ ]
because like
i think anyone who has an upbringing or
even south african parents kind of know
that there's a
there's a sternness with south african
people that is
i i've never experienced it in the uk
i've never experienced it in the uk but
when i was growing up south africa and
i'd go around my friend's houses or
whatever i'd realized that there was
definitely there's definitely a
different personality trait there
that's so stern and he he was always
very um
you know no jokes no it's so serious
and i've got this um with it even within
myself i
i recognize characteristics that i've
got from like my mom
and my dad and i've got this this
serious streak that runs through me a
little bit sometimes
i i clock myself and i'm being like
you're being way too serious about this
situation you need to like
chill out a little bit and um
so yeah yeah i mean south
south africa is kind of a rough place to
grow up right
i mean when i was growing up there i
i was so young so i didn't really
see or understand or really you know i
didn't see
the whole thing i just saw what children
see which is um
fun stuff like the beach and um
having my own pool which was amazing
and all the cool things so everything
kind of went over my head but there is
definitely difficulties about living
there i mean i haven't been back
since i was 11. and
i feel so i mean i shouldn't i shouldn't
feel like this but i've got
such an apprehension of going back i'm
not sure what it is i think it's
maybe destroying this idea of what i
created
that was my childhood because i
cherished my childhood it's
it's it's like a perfect little chapter
of my
life and i don't want to go back and see
you know see it and be like oh this
isn't how i remembered it
so it's a tricky one does your dad live
there still or is he also in england
yeah he lives there
oh okay yeah so there's a lot of space
between you guys as well
yeah but i think his i mean his his
upbringing there must have been really
tough because i know south africa went
through some really crazy stuff
in the past you know yeah
his upbringing was really really shitty
so i imagine that's why
he is like he is so i understand i
understand that
um i know there was a lot of
shitty things that happened back back
then
when he was growing up because he was
born there so his parents and all this
i'm not sure if his parents were and
honestly i really
i know my mom's side of the family but i
really am unsure it gets all because i
don't speak to him and
he never really spoke to me much as a
kid either so it's kind of hard to
pin pinpoint this whole uh whatever
happened there
but he doesn't speak about it his
history much
um dan is telling me that we need to go
to break
so we will throw to a quick break and be
right back with bill delphine
so liquid iv
okay it's a little packet of schmutz
you pour it in a water drink and you
drink it
now let me tell you about the genius of
liquid iv it's to help hydrate and
energize you
this is the one that i've been chugging
lately it's got caffeine
in it which is actually good for me
because the caffeine is really acidic
and it gives me heartburn
so this one's got like two hits of
caffeine in it
it's got ginseng matcha
i don't know what that says why soap
ginse it's got all this stuff
and all these like it's like pedialyte
it's got all these essential minerals
and stuff it picks you up
it energizes you it hydrates you liquid
iv
i love it they've got all these
different like uh type formulas too
so this one's energy this one's like
we'll we'll pick you up in the morning
with caffeine and get yolk
ready to go then they've got like the uh
the hydration formula just to hydrate
you
and then this one's for immune support
which is really loaded with vitamin c
and all this stuff like
let's see you know
so i i've done all of them and it's
really great
i actually it's awesome put some ice in
there it's a nice refreshing beverage
and
that caffeine one is like shot out of a
cannon boy i was like really
off the walls yeah oh yeah dude i made
it i cleared the whole game
i've been played in hades i took one of
those caffeine
shots full cleared that [ __ ]
easy you know you got flu season coming
up that's why you want to do the immune
support
you've got you're trying to stay
hydrated if you're hungover even you
want to do the hydration one
you know what i'm saying it's all
happening
one serving of liquid iv provides the
same hydration as drinking two or three
bottles of water alone
it's almost like a water paradox we
don't need water anymore how does that
work
it's a water paradox probably because
it's got like the minerals and the
hydration stuff that you would get from
two or three
glasses of water you know three
delicious new flavors sweet
and juicy guava crisp watermelon and
comforting
apple pie it contains five essential
vitamins more vitamin c than an orange
and much more potassium
of a banana you know if you don't get
enough potassium you get
that's how you get cramps so if you get
really bad cramps
do this eat it or or eat a banana but do
this
you know it's healthier than sugary
sports drinks
it doesn't have any artificial flavors
or preservatives and it has less sugar
than an apple it's made with clean
ingredients non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy and soy
the uh what makes liquid iv so effective
well it's got the optimal ratio of
glucose sodium and potassium
delivered via the water and nutrients
right into your bloodstream it's the
perfect balance to help you hydrate
more quickly and effectively than water
alone one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water can give as much
hydration
as two to three bottles of plain water
they're on a mission to change the world
they've donated over 5 million ser
servings of this stuff globally
in response to kova 19 products are
being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks uh veterans
active us military and that's over three
million servings so far so they're also
saints
that's really nice besides making a
great product liquid iv is available
nationwide at walmart
in the beverage section or you can get
25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
code h3
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order
when you use the promo code h3 at
liquidity.com
better hydration today at liquidity.com
promo code
h3 honey
honey honey honey look we all know
what's going on here
there's coupons on the internet just
taunting you
laughing in your face because you're
paying full price at your favorite
online
store and you didn't know that there was
a coupon for 10
20 30 40 50 off and it's just laughing
in your face
that's where honey comes in to stop the
laughter and get serious
they browse the internet automatically
at checkout
for the best coupons available for the
website you're shopping on
to make sure that your ass never misses
out on a deal
again it's a free browser extension
takes two clicks to install it's easy
as pie it has thirty thousand supported
sites
all you gotta do is click apply coupon
when it pops up at checkout you wait a
few seconds it searches for coupons on
that site
and if honey finds a working code boom
slam dams thank you ma'am here's e-level
shopping the other day i'm leaving
it's really the best i was shopping here
items that were already on sale
so normally i wouldn't even try to look
for any additional discount
and then honey did this it was like
pretty much another 50
off i mean how much was the product like
200 bucks
this is the total 220. oh i see and it's
a straight up 50
off yeah that's insane yeah that's
insane
that's the power of honey folks they've
saved 17 million members over two
billion dollars
they support all kinds of retailers from
tech gaming sites fashion browns and
even food delivery
it's simple if you have a computer honey
should be on it it's free
and works with whatever browser you use
you can get honey for free today at
joinhoney.com
h3 that's join honey dot com slash h3
so they know that we sent you thank you
very much
and thank you to honey for sponsoring
today's episode
welcome back we were just talking about
how trash tv rules you know
we started watching like i think our
first trashy
show was like 90 day fiance or something
that's true
and i just got hooked on like the
trashier the better like
i'm like 30 junky now and i need i need
like my hit to be even stronger every
time
and i think the bachelor's is probably
the trashiest show oh my god
but also the highest production value
which i guess that's why it feels like
next level
it's a more lethal dose yeah you
would you enjoy trash tv i
love it but as you said it kind of the
level needs to get more intense each
time it's like
i want several fights on this episode
because there's one
last episode so this one needs to be
more you know
that's what this season of the
bachelorette feels like like the last
episode it's like every minute felt like
the season is ending right now like this
is i'll tell you what happened just i
mean
sorry spoiler or whatever but i don't
care ever all the guys
you know the premise of the show right
yeah so all the guys
walked out because they were so over her
they [ __ ] left the show i'm telling
you it i i don't know how they do it it
gets better every season
they literally just bounce they don't
yeah what if they don't like the main
person i always wanted that because they
don't
meant to chase this person right so what
if they're like no
yeah and you well usually the the main
person has so many flaws
they don't have a job and i think it
turns into this whole thing of like
the scarcity where she's like the only
woman in the world and they all get in
the competition with themselves all
these alpha males
so i think they totally lose sight of
the fact that they actually have to
be with this person she's just like her
personality's like hey
i'm hot pretty much that's pretty much
her personality
but god this season yes that's amazing
ian's watching it too i recommend
everybody get on the bachelor
act so um but
back to the topic yes i did not come
here to discuss the bachelorette
um
so are you waiting to do porn are you
easing your mom into it is that is there
a strategy to this
um i think just when the time's right
i think with everything that i've done
online i've always felt comfortable
doing it so it took me i mean even when
i turned 18 it still took me six months
to be comfortable
to do lose stuff and then from then on i
just you know kind of
up the notch and up the notch so each
time i've always felt comfortable doing
it
so i'm just waiting for you know when i
feel
comfortable to do that i just heard the
battle cry of a million
you know did it feel super crazy the
first time you put out a nude photo i
have to imagine because you said you had
to like psych yourself
up to it over six months that it must
have been like
felt super crazy to put a nude photo of
yourself online for the first time
no because it's always been in stages
it's always been in stages so
it's always you know you'll do a photo
like this and then you'll do a phrase
like this and then it's like this and
then it's just
it's so it's so normal like for one
example i can compare it to this when i
started getting into like
kawaii fashion because i lived in a very
small english
town and i'm sure it's like the same as
like a small american town in the middle
of texas or something
it's um everyone's the same and everyone
knows you and
everyone will look at you so i started
getting into kawaii fashion
and i felt like okay this is just going
to be something i wear inside because i
i don't want attention outside in the
real world that's too much
and then i bought this one pair of shoes
and these these shoes were like big
platform shoes and i was like i love
them i love them so much i want to wear
them every day
so i i just one day i was like
i am gonna wear these shoes outside so i
wore them
and i was prying the whole day i was
like everyone is looking at me this is
so embarrassing
and then the second day i wore them i
was like oh this is embarrassing
and then the more i wore them it was
just easy and now i can just wear them
and be like these are my casual shoes
you know
so it's just getting comfortable with
things um
you always have to push yourself the
first step first step is always the
hardest
and then slowly pushing yourself it just
gets easier and easier and then
you know you'll look back in the past
and be like whoa you know
who was that or whatever that's true and
fast forward uh
you know a year and you'll be doing a
gangbang on block.com
exactly and be wondering who is this shy
laura
um but people like for example you did
that troll on pornhub
i think it was an april fool's joke and
people were genuinely
mad right just just to give some
background
belle was like i'm finally making a
pornhub account and she uploaded
videos of her like petting my [ __ ] and
it was her with a cat but she did like
20. they were all really funny
yeah i mean you put the effort in it
wasn't like a cheap gadget definitely
put the work in for that one
but you're but some of your fans were
seriously
angry did that surprise you
no no i didn't
i knew i was gonna get that response
again i had the same feeling i was like
oh should i do this
that's so funny i would never think that
people would be so genuinely mad
actually that might be the first time i
heard about you is because i think maybe
that was the first time
i was like these guys yeah i think maybe
that was the first time and i was like
i think that's the first time we talked
about i think that's the first time i
heard the word simp
oh interesting i mean that was my
introduction yeah
and i was just so blown away by how
genuinely pissed people
were and i think i was more interested
in that than anything
um yeah do you get like hate mail and
[ __ ] where they're like
you [ __ ] i was gonna beat off this day i
had my lotion and my tissue and now
um see what i've noticed is i've
really noticed a difference in hate
right there's a certain type of hate i
get from girls and there's a certain
type of pain i get from guys the hair i
get from
guys is so uh
plateau it's so all the same it's just
like
um you know you don't you don't show
this you don't do
this um you're it's just baseline insult
it sounds like
ugly you know it's just like you're ugly
blah blah blah but with girls right
they are so strategic they
will pinpoint the exact things that
they can analyze from photos what i'm
insecure about and then they will
blow it up right and they will you know
guys just say like oh you're ugly
girls they will be like the proportion
of this
is wrong look at it zoomed up multiple
photos lined up and it's like
it's crazy it's so different
oh my god they're really going for it
they know they know that that baseline
right they are not nice about it right
where it hurts
oh my god so the baseline do the girls
know how to get you the dudes are like
i want to beat off and i'm angry because
i can't yeah but the girl's like i'm
gonna [ __ ] this girl's whole life up
i think the girls know what kind of
things would hurt them
so they right you know they know exactly
the strengths to pull to make you feel a
certain way
it sounds like most of the hate doesn't
bother you but some of the hate does
yeah i mean i've had like i've had some
really
really harsh levels of hate like i've
had i mean this is quite personal but
when i was dating my ex-boyfriend um
i i broke up with him it was completely
you know
mutual or whatever maybe it wasn't that
mutual
but it it was still it was still
a breakup's difficult it's very
difficult
and i the the girls they caught on to
this right they knew
that a breakup had happened and
basically what happened was my
ex-boyfriend
slept with our mutual friend and the
girls found out about this and then they
started putting side-by-side
photos of my friend and me
because my ex had slept with how could
they figure it out so i'd like to
compare the two of you
they they find out everything they found
out everything it's crazy but
they um so they started like
uh comparing our facial features to each
other and all this stuff and
and it obviously it hurt it was pretty
cool yeah it was uh next level
that is next level wow and like
this is like a res that's like a dark
part of the internet i wouldn't even
know where to find something like that
it's on forms and stuff i mean there's
been so many
different levels of um uncomfortable and
scary
factors of doing this job that i just
wouldn't have
expected from the beginning like my
address
being doxed and people coming to my
house and then um
the whole this girl so
unfortunate she got she was like an
e-girl and she got
um killed basically and i was everywhere
on internet because she was um
an eagle right and then i was
you know i was interested in this story
because obviously she's
you know similar really i've related to
her whatever
but by what she was interested in and i
was looking at the comments and there
was a comment and it had a thousand
likes on it
saying bel delphine should be next and i
was just like
that it's it's just i mean
you know hate doesn't bother me at all
you can say anything right but there's
some level of comments like saying
i saw one recently and they get so
intense it's like
i would like to see bel delphine's
severed head on best school
and it's just wow it
feels it feels
just icky you know it feels icky because
i have had people come to my house
and it just feels icky yeah i didn't
like it
do you have security i mean do you have
any some extra level of security for
your
yes yeah good yeah good good yeah that
was my that was my first priority
yeah yeah but you're so right those are
the things you
are not even aware of when you go into
this kind of
job if you can call it a job you know
when you start it you don't even really
know if it's a job
it just things kind of just go but um
yeah it's wild you have to become like
an expert on
security and pr and i don't know it's
just
you're your own team too like we don't
have handlers and
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot to learn
more than just making the content
yeah why do
you ever think about like why do these
people hate me so much i mean it's just
like what
what am i like why i know i know you're
like provocative and stuff but these
people are talking about killing you i
mean
it's like what i don't know it's just it
just seems so obscene it's so unfair so
ridiculous
i guess the thing is like i can kind of
understand because there's this whole
i mean there's there's subcultures of
everything right on the internet
and there's subcultures of people who
like gore and they watch all this stuff
and i suppose if a
if a hot girl or whatever on the
internet eagle dies and there's
can you it's just like it's like um such
a big story
i mean wouldn't it be you know if i died
or something
can you imagine the amount of people
that would comment on it make tweets
about it talk about it it would be
it'd be um because people on the
internet feel
relatable right and you can kind of it's
it's different to tv and mainstream
media
it's kind of feels like more like a girl
next door type of thing so if i died
it's just
the the drama and the gossip or whatever
from that
is would be interesting it'd be
interesting to just
view and i suppose for the people who
like things like gore i mean
would be great for them i said yeah
i think it's also just the there's also
the other
um side to it it's just the more success
um that you get for people who
don't have that success and they're just
at home
and they don't see how to get out of
their situation they're like
all she does is this and she's so
successful and it's like it
comes into hate you know it's it's from
their bitterness
and sometimes i get really mean comments
you know and it's like
yeah i guess you you kind of just have
to compar to car
like just try to compare to mentalize it
because it's they don't know you right
they don't know who you are as a person
but
yeah that doesn't feel good certainly
um any other hazards of your
of your line of work that you didn't see
coming
oh um let me think about it
um i mean you mentioned
having a boyfriend that i wonder how is
that
like dating or dating in general yeah
you know what's interesting is i've got
i've got so many friends that kind of do
what i do
and it hasn't impacted their
relationship at all i feel like so many
girls so many girls haven't only fans
nowadays right that's true
um and it just maybe maybe i'm in this
certain world and i'm i'm in this bubble
and i'm not quite seeing the bigger
picture of um
normal relationships or something but
within my whole world
it doesn't impact the relationship at
all so
i really haven't seen it
it just feels so normal once you're in
this world oh my god it's just like
uh being an accountant or whatever and
you're just speaking about an
accountancy it's so
just like normal what do you think
there's like this whole
um movement like i saw this one
conservative guy tweet out the other day
he goes
he says sex work isn't real work
do you feel like what what is this
movement about of people trying to
delegitimize your kind of your business
do you think of it as a business do you
do i mean do you disagree with that
statement
i mean technically what i do is a
business because i've got a whole
business structure
set up and all this you know rubbish
um but i definitely don't feel like i'm
a professional person i've never been a
professional type of person what i do is
so um
it's more i mean it's just like on the
creative
field it's not nothing what i do is i'm
very
professional and maybe that's how these
people view jobs you have to be
very like this is my job i'm a student
thai
i'm very adult or whatever and i can
understand from their perspective where
they're coming from
because you just got to understand
if if i look from their perspective
right i see girl taking photos in
her own room like that's not a job like
what is that
i can understand from their perspective
but
i think there's so many different levels
where it
really does become a job sure yeah for
sure
i think um
i mean i don't even really
likely think that people have to argue
on this it just seems so
pointless well yeah they're trying to
demean you you're yeah
being like i think it's the same
bitterness that
yeah um to me there isn't even a
question
what what is even you may make yeah
whatever but yeah you're
less upset about it than us so i guess
there's really
there's no point to the conversation
i've heard you talk about daddy dom
i don't know what daddy dom is are you
into daddy dom and can you explain what
daddy dom
is i think i read that in your patreon
profile or something
yeah yeah there's loads of different
levels to
any type of kink so there's there's a
whole spectrum
to danny dumb right yeah so you can get
into it as deep as you want to um but
what would be the deepest level of daddy
dom
just to kind of give us some parameters
here
it's a very it's so controversial just
want to say i'm not into the deep end of
it but if you were to go
deep into it i mean it's just acting
like a you know like a baby wearing
nappies
you [ __ ] in your diaper and all that and
they change you
yeah you [ __ ] the baby though
because that's what it is right
right i mean that's what it is i did not
i just i think i made her speechless
because that's
does daddy [ __ ] you i mean it sounds it
is messed up and so i'm wondering
okay i think that's that's the far end
level of it right
but i think the main spectrum
of it is the fact that girls find
calling their partners
daddy because it shows dominance
it's not necessarily a father figure
unless
you view it that way it can be it can be
but i think on the most side of it it's
just another word
in play with things like master or
what's another word that people use you
know this kind of dominant
label that uh asserts this
thing of power like you know the whole
teacher student role play thing
it says power exchange and with danny i
think it's kind of like a casual word
of this that um can just be used
casually i suppose so you're
you're submissive in other words
yeah yeah you're like the um the little
thing that's
cherished that can be like naughty and
playful and bratty and
you can you can tease like your daddy
and things like that
and um the daddy i think the main
important thing is that daddy looks
after you
and um uh yeah
and so have you ever put on a diaper and
[ __ ] your diaper
no no i have never done that
all right because when i hear daddy dom
i'm like oh this shit's freaky with the
pacifier
and the diaper and you're in a crib and
he's changing your diaper and all this i
was like oh [ __ ] that's freaky
saying daddy's actually become really
mainstream now though i see it
like media everywhere do you call your
uh i don't know if you're in a
relationship but if you were would you
call
them daddy just casually around the
house
um i think yeah i'd definitely like to
i definitely like to r kelly would like
that
but see he would like that but actually
when you described it it made so much
more sense because if he's your daddy
he's supposed to cherish you and protect
you right
so that whole aspect i think was lost on
r kelly
yeah but how much how how much does that
say is [ __ ] up about r kelly when he
says call me daddy and then he pees on
them
see that's not cherishing that's not a
good dad that's a bad dad
you like good dad not bad daddy
do you think your interest in daddy dom
has possibly any connection with the
fact that like you are estranged from
your dad
do you ever wonder about how that may
affect your life
okay first off i want to say when i say
daddy i am
not thinking of my dad yeah right that
is not that's not what happens
but i think
probably to be honest there's there's um
there's a
a caringness you know a uh a real
attentiveness
that i think i probably would have um
should have probably had more during my
childhood which is why
i cherish it so much now i think it's
like the best thing to be cared for
and to be um you know have someone
attend for me like i i obviously out of
10 for them as well
but it's just this this caring
nature that i think is a really really
nice
i mean i know this is a kink right but
there's such a wholesome
wholesomeness to it it's just um uh
no yeah caringness no i like the way you
described it it makes
it actually makes sense to me now when i
didn't understand it before so
thank you for that appreciate that can
you be can you have a mommy if i want to
be like a little boy
see it seems to be a pretty primarily
female thing the daddy dom thing but
mommy dom you want to be my mommy no
nice i tried i don't like
the mommy it doesn't sound like sexy to
me yeah i mean i know you're not
thinking about your parents but i prefer
to keep the
whole thing
i would like you to nurture me more
though i would like you to baby me more
i think i baby you though yeah babies
okay whatever you say cut your toenails
no she doesn't do that where's my mommy
at don't know flipping damn
what else what else should she do for me
keep going i know
i was just saying general that's like
something that like some
couples like uh do if they're like
really careful i mean
what what do other couples do in what in
this dynamic
yeah i know they're i know of women who
like pimping popping pimples is that a
mommy thing
or is that just a freak i think that's
just a girlfriend thing
just well some girls i've known girls
who love it they'll like seek it out
like i want to pop your pimple
but like i think i find it disgusting
ela hates it and i agree with her okay
do you like popping pimples
oh i'd love to publish them that's so
satisfying
it doesn't gross you out
it's like i mean why do you think
there's a show dedicated to popping
pictures no i know
people love it so hold on do you like dr
pimple popper
yeah [ __ ] cause this some of the stuff's
on there is pretty gnarly it's way
beyond like your normal like i'm gonna
pop your pitbull they're like i'm gonna
take this 20-pound
sis and it's gonna be like buckets of
us but that you like that
gnarlier the better you gotta go
man i saw some we watched we watched uh
we did a segment on the podcast where we
watched some of the gnarly [ __ ] i mean
there is some
really horrific horrific yeah
stuff those images are burned in my head
um uh
do you consider yourself an artist at
all because you know when we got your
mystery box we're like you know this
person's an
artist this person's a performing artist
was what she's doing
do you accept that
um i think no
no i mean obviously there's levels of
everything that i do that
is creative like today i did a halloween
spooky spooky halloween
it's just fun playing with creativity
things i mean making your box
was so fun it was it was the most fun
thing i've done in so long
um and i think
i mean everything kind of everything on
the internet has creativity i mean you
guys
making your own videos you just to think
of a concept to elaborate on that and
then to actually
perform it of course requires levels of
creativity
i feel like you take the eagle thing to
the new level though i just i maybe i
just want to give you
a little bit of credit and just how
you've like um
really elevated your your field let's
say
um
i don't really want to i like well i'm
giving you the compliment
you don't have to accept it but it is
what it is
thank you thank you um
so what what is your main um
like medium or platform that you
would say is the best thing for you is
it only fans or
yeah only fans i mean i
i don't really post youtube videos and i
post
so rarely on twitter but the thing is on
my only fans i'm posting about 40
pictures a day
oh wow holy videos as well i i try and
be
as active as i possibly can so even
though technically
it looks like i'm really dead on the
internet right i'm posting as much as i
can on my only fans because
i mean people pay me for it and i like
doing it so
oh wow that's great that's a good plug
for your only fans
zack you're subscribed right do you have
what do you want to review or have any
requests for her
uh that's fantastic zach why do you why
do you have anything you have to say so
sleazy bro come on just give her no no
it's you you are an artist you really
are you really you really are an artist
belle
and i do appreciate that um it has this
great
artistic element to it more than just
like a sexual thing
yeah right like you care about that it's
i do i'm an artist too
um but um yeah it's really cool
it's definitely worth the money can i
just say zack i love your tick
oh tocks god by the way did you see the
one where he was making fun of the girl
in the skirt
yes oh my god got him
[Laughter]
yeah we're going to do a whole segment
we're going to do all segment on zach
dick talk because
he's keeping it going and i got to say
they're saying strong
someone collecting his tick tocks oh
yeah preparing for a content court yeah
you know um did
the only fans thing is relatively new
for you did that change your whole life
yeah i mean yeah i it was crazy because
i left the internet for a year i thought
my career was over
i i was like i'm gonna have to move out
of my house because i can't afford it
anymore
and i i i was i was so in the mindset of
thinking i had this opportunity
and it's completely gone and
everything's
hold on let me back up here because i
remember you disappeared
is that after instagram deleted your
account
yeah instagram got taken down i tried to
make a new one got deleted as well
and then i was trying to think about
what different avenues i could go down
and i just came to a complete road stop
so i was like i'm gonna
i need to think about this and it took
me a year
i was just moping in my own sad space
thinking that i've lost
everything and then this is
so dumb how this even happened right i
hate that
um it's spurred from this but
but basically my idea was i'm gonna make
these mystery boxes right i was thinking
about this so
far ahead of the time like months before
i came back i was like i'm gonna make
these mystery boxes to all the people
that i really really love on the
internet
i'm going to send it to them and that
will be a way because i want to do this
anyway i want to
like give out gifts and hand make things
because i enjoy doing this stuff in my
spare time i just wanted a purpose to do
it
so i was like that would be great and
like it would get my name back on the
internet and then i could come back
somehow
and then i was doing that and then i
heard the new goober video right
and i was like this video is genius he's
just come back from jail
and it's an i'm back video i need to use
this for
my etho i'm back right it's a colorful
video
i i i need to replicate this so i
literally
same day i saw the video i went back and
i
started working on it i painted all my
walls
and i thought of like the shots that i
was going to do and i just filmed it
and then i posted it and it got like 36
or 5 or whatever million views the views
are insane wow
and that that was when you announced
that you were doing lonely fans right
yeah because i was going to come back on
any fans and only fans has done really
well
really well i'm surprised that you took
it so hard to be honest with you that
you
really because you know a lot of people
were trying to guess like where'd she go
what happened to her
and you know not really as
i mean you're such a fixture on the
internet that people just like following
your hijinks like on the show we talk we
talk about you
quite frequently when you're up to all
your antics and it was a really
great interesting subject for us to talk
about
but i would never imagine that you
actually thought that your career was
dead because instagram deleted your
account
i mean you have followers and you had
support all over the place
the thing is my instagram was at such a
level of
crazy interactions i had like 200 000
comments per just photo right yeah so
i was already plugged in with the idea
that this was my normal right i'd post a
photo
and get thousands of comments and
thousands like
million two million likes per photo and
this was my normal
yeah it was it was so crazy and i kind
of
got i was like i've got this this
megalomania of a platform that's doing
amazing and then boom
it went just like that and then i was
like right
[ __ ] okay what do i have left i've got a
i've got a twitter that gets like 3 000
likes per thing and i was like i'm dead
that's it
i'm dead even though that's great even
though my twitter yeah no
i got it i was just used to like this
level you didn't see the path anymore
of like yeah where are you gonna go
it's it's easy to build up like this
it's
really hard to come back when you go
there to come back
did you how were you making money back
then when you were on instagram you had
a patreon
yeah i had a patreon which is pretty
much like a more
safe for work version of what i'm doing
on only fans
so that continued through through that
period right or did you you disappeared
from patreon too right
i literally left the internet i i didn't
i mean during this year that i was gone
i pretty much
didn't go on the internet at all because
whenever i went i just feel so
shitty about everything that happened
what was that like
the being away from it for a year
um so bad at the beginning i was just
i mean i couldn't i could i just
i was thinking in my mind like i can't
you know when you move out for the first
time
it's amazing you're not under the roof
of your mom your mom doesn't have to
tell you like do your laundry
you got to do the washing and i just
gotten used to this
being the the king of my own
household and i was like i really can't
go back
now i i can't go back and being told
what i
have to do or things like that um
it was hard i took it really hard at the
beginning and then six months down the
line
i just started hanging out with my
friends again and that was really good
and i traveled a little bit before you
know corona and everything and that was
really good and it gave me
it made me breathe again and it made me
think
okay that's all good but you know
i was i was still in the place where i'm
like i can't afford my house if i don't
do something so i really had to
do something so i did it that was sort
of
you know the whole thing was weird
because your account i mean it was
obviously
provocative but i've seen tons of
accounts with
showing the same amount i mean you
weren't nude in it did they ever give
you a reason why or is it just like see
ya
i think it was nudity which like you
know
sexually explicit which is
i i was like that sucks but like 50
percent of what instagram is it's
weird because yeah i see it all the time
on instagram you know was it true
i think there was like angry simps over
the pornhub thing that were like
mass reporting your account is that what
happened
i mean i probably did get mass reported
because that's usually how
the the different counts work like i
think
i think that's how the algorithm works
but i'm not too sure
i couldn't say how did you find out like
uh when did you first find out your
account was
was shut down and then kind of how did
that feel like
um well i had like troubles with it
before
and it kind of came back after a day or
like a week so honestly this time i
wasn't
stressed about it i was like it's gonna
come back of course it's gonna come back
you know and then it didn't come back
and i think
it really hit me like the month
afterwards when i
you know i i you feel lost
you feel lost as like an internet person
when your life is
on the internet i mean my life has been
for so many years
i've been an internet person i've all my
friends were on the internet
and to have this just taken away
i mean it's kind of crazy how big
those things are for us i mean you spend
like almost the whole day on it
it's like a part of you i mean it's a
connection it's a connect
the internet is a connection thing you
know it connects so many different
people all around the world to each
other it's so much more than just the
picture website or whatever you know all
these things have so much
meaning to each other you know you you
have such value on certain things
sorry to go deep on you it's kind of a
problem in a way because you have
these are like privately owned companies
but now they have so much important in
our life
and then the fact that they can just
erase your account and [ __ ] your life up
like that
it's pretty wild yeah you know
so you've made it through you are the
queen of only fans now
sir you do you feel like you're in a
better place now now since that you went
through all that
yes yeah yes i i'm so relieved because i
really thought it was i thought it was
i thought i was done for but now i'm
just
it just feels like i've woken up
and i'm in a really good place and it
feels so
good to feel comfortable to just feel
comfortable in this own little space of
the internet i mean only fans is good
with
you know sexual content so i know that
regardless of what happens
they're not going to get rid of me right
so it's a safe place and a good place to
be
yeah i'm happy i'm happy for you you
know it seems like you're
it seems like you're really in a good
place why is it that you're on this show
right now because you've you've been so
secretive you know your whole career
so all of a sudden you're on a podcast
you just did another podcast too
max mofo's podcast so what is
now uh why the change of heart
um thing is i've always had like
quite a a difficult relationship with my
own voice
as in i've always hated my voice and
i've never liked
speaking and even like with friends or
whatever i'd never be the one speaking
because i just i just hates it so i've
always been so shy about it i mean even
with the bath water video or any of
these videos
it takes me so many records to get a
a video that i'm comfortable with and
even then i'm like oh
this sounds i just hate it i feel
uncomfortable with it you know
um and i think that is part to play
from when i because when i moved to the
uk i had the
strongest south african voice ever it
was so
thick and you know in a small town in
england it was you know i had a weird
different accent and everyone
loves being like oh this is a weird
accent and they'd like
to be all weird and funny about me so i
was really insecure about that so i made
sure to try my hardest to speak
the most english i could speak so i
could sound like them
so that they didn't um you know pick on
me or whatever in this weird way i
wouldn't call it bullying it's just kids
being kids
but i've always had a weird relationship
with it so when i was on the internet i
tried to always think of ideas that
didn't require me to use my voice
so small videos of me eating something
weird or throwing something weird on my
face or
doing certain things i think the only
thing that required me was certain
youtube videos which i'd pre
like record afterwards as well but
now i'm just in the place where
i just want to move this away i just
want to move it away and i want to do
what i want on the internet because the
internet is fun
and the internet's a good place and i
want to be able to speak to people
and i don't want to be this 2d person
anymore because i think i am more than
that even if i'm not the funniest
or the most interesting person on the
internet i still want to
show who i am beyond how i look
i'm really happy you're doing that
because i feel like
we felt that there is a lot more to you
and um
just being only kind of like behind the
character all the time
it it kind of gets um like
yeah like it's just so narrow sometimes
and i think for you to be able to grow
and go other places or just
expand and this is so much better and
i think for us it's really nice to get
to know you and it
i mean you're definitely an interesting
person so
like i wouldn't worry about that yeah i
mean i wanted to have you on the show
ever since ever for a while so i'm
really happy that that it
got to finally happen and you know i'm
sure that other things will come up i
hope you're
you're down because i'm sure that zach
is going to do this or that and we'd
love to you know
get bella's opinion on that or whatever
is going on
for example here okay okay good
well for example do you wipe from the
front or the back
okay i was thinking about this before
because i know you asked this to every
person
i was thinking about this before so i
was at the loo and i was like
concentrating like okay what do
what do i do and then i realize i think
i do something that's
it might be different i wipe separately
so i if i'm wiping like you know my
my butt even though i don't really poop
because that's disgusting
but if i am i'll just you know do that
bit
and then if i'm doing my front i'll just
do that oh you do it except for what
but when yeah that's really interesting
do you ever do both at the same time
how would you be able to reach i don't
know i don't have a vagina what do i
know
and so huh well that's a new but when
you wipe well when you
that is new but like when you wipe the
ass do you go
under or or like front or back you know
i'll just like
lift my butt up a bit and like arch
forward and then like you know
you're you're proper you're a proper
girl fair enough this one's from zach
so forgive me he asks belle
we see that you follow fleshlight on
twitter zack seriously
would you ever consider having a bell
delphine sex toy
exactly so inappropriate oh my god
so yes i was actually speaking to them
about it
and then i realized that well i mean
obviously it has to be a real mold of
your
[ __ ] right yeah so i was like
okay if i do this everyone will be able
to see what my
[ __ ] is like no problem with that which
people haven't seen
right yeah no people haven't seen that
so i'm kind of if i do reveal that i
think i'd want to do it in a more epic
way than
like yeah it's on
but that's the next logical uh step so
so zach there's a chance yes that that's
going to be coming to fruition
god you're going to make so much money
from that thing dude
i wonder what's your cut do you know
what you're cut on a fleshlight if
you're like if it's you
i i don't know what the cut would be
you know it should be a pretty good yeah
we get a pretty good cut from that
you know what i mean you know they have
like mouths and buttholes would you ever
do like a mouth mold
oh yeah that would i would actually do
that so your mouth
out there dude people you're ready
people are ready for that zach would you
be happy with the mouth or would you
need the
vagina i feel like anything anything
zach
do it all right
yeah i feel like that would be a good
niche to like do
the first ever ear flashlight beldolfine
people would buy it i'm pretty sure
there'd be plenty of purchases
okay okay um
you believe in ghosts have you ever seen
a ghost a ufo or anything like that
it's a really really weird one
i think yes yes i've had
one really i mean i don't
the thing is i hate speaking about this
stuff i hate speaking about this stuff
because
everyone's like everyone's like oh
really wow that happened
and nobody believes you i'm not i'm not
i'm not dumb
right i understand because i've heard
other people's ghost stories and i'm
like
yeah but there is a logical explanation
behind it obviously
like like plumbing or something making a
noise or like something in your head
that
sounds like a voice or something i
understand but
there was this one time i feel so dumb
saying this story but but
i was you know at home in my room
on my computer as always don't know what
i was doing
but it was really late because i always
stayed up late because like sleeping pan
is always nocturnal
and then my bed just [ __ ] moved i'm
not even you're
taking me my bed you look underneath
moved
no i was you know when you feel like
paralyzed and you're like oh was that me
breathe
it it was weird it was very so weird i
kind of always think about it what kind
of movement was it was it like a big
jolt
did it like scoot to the side did it
drag what happened to you
it was like if you were to it wasn't
like this
it was more like this so it went away
from the wall at one side
and there's the thing is i've thought
about it and there's no explanation
explanation for it oh so you were i
don't understand i don't understand
so how did you react you just stayed in
bed kind of just paralyzed with fear
i literally waited there until the
sun came up because it was late at the
time and i just waited until the sun
came
up and then when i heard my mom waking
up and she was making breakfast you know
you kind of feel
safe when you start hearing these like
other people
awake and that's the point where i kind
of like got awake and i looked under the
bed obviously nothing was there
and i've just to this day i've never
been able to
understand it myself and i feel like
there's no point telling people because
i was the only one there
what am i meant to say it was just weird
interesting thing that happened
weird thing that happened is it possible
you were you are wide awake when it
happened is it possible you were
dreaming
and you thought you were awake or
something like that no
absolutely not i've had no record of me
ever doing something like that
no and you're sure the bed moved you got
up and you looked and it was out of its
place
there there first off there's no way to
like
you can't jolt a bed like that unless
you're on a
small metal frame bed or something you
can't move it with your body
and when i woke up because i woke up it
was light outside my mum was there i was
checking under the
bed and i walked away and the bed was
away from the wall
so the bed moved the bed
moved the bed move and it
freaks me out and it skips with tingles
down my body
yeah that's cool what about you guys i
nothing
the only thing that comes to mind is
like
i was really young when it happened so i
can write it off as like who really
knows what happened
but i woke up in the middle of the night
i was a really young kid
or actually maybe in the morning i don't
know and
um i had a little window facing the
backyard
and i remember looking at the window and
a face looked through
and it was like the creep it was pretty
high window i remember that it was high
up
like eight feet up or something you know
so it was tall whatever it was that was
always my nightmare
like to look at a window and all of a
sudden see your face but it was like a
[ __ ] up
face like a frankenstein looking face
just staring at me
and then it went away geez so it was
like staring at me and then it went away
and i was so freaked out i just tried to
go back to sleep and i just have that
that one memory that's the only time it
could have been anything i mean
it could have been a person for all i
know i don't [ __ ] know maybe
i know what it was i know what it was it
was a premonition of you thinking of you
as uncle fester
and seeing your reflection as yeah the
lightning yeah
maybe it was me as uncle festa yeah
it's like one of those weird time loops
yeah well i never went back in time as
uncle fester maybe you've
closed maybe you don't know yet yeah
closed up already
did you like my outfits did you where
have you been watching for enemies
i've been watching all of them and the
courts
yeah yeah yeah absolutely amazing that's
awesome thank you so much
what do you think about dudes that pee
in their basements turn on or turn off
[Laughter]
oh my god i pee in my basement
oh there you go you would pee in your
basement
i just peed in my basement
do you have the sound bite zack oh zack
is not functioning yeah zack scott i
don't know if he's got his hands on his
keyboard right now i was
playing it can you hear it oh no no he
can't hear it
yeah i've been playing him oh
um do you want are you really a gamer
girl do you game
what games do you like uh
i do game kinda but not in the way
that's like
i i didn't think i would categorize
myself as a gamer girl at all i used to
play
so much runescape back in the day
that's why i added the buying gf thing
on your books
yeah i never you know i don't know if
you remember everquest i used that used
to be my game i never played runescape
i think it was around the same period
yeah yeah
and uh do you have any favorite anime
shows or television shows that you're
currently watching or want to recommend
um i mean i think for anyone that hasn't
watched
an anime before your name such a good
beautiful movie oh is that the super sad
one that i keep hearing about
yeah yeah you should watch it wait is
that a miyazaki one or no no
is that his new movie no okay uh no i
don't think so
yeah i hate sad stuff i just i get i get
so emotional
it'll ruin my whole week there's more to
it than it being sad it just happened
something sad okay you could choose you
could choose
to laugh at it if you really wanted to
be a psychopath
doesn't have to be a sad movie
i guess that's good advice for anything
you do in life
and i guess my psychopath my final
question which i think we've got some
insight into but where do you see your
career going
from here what's the next step for belle
delphine
black.com besidesblack.com well
it depends i think i might end up giving
the people what they want
oh
nice what's the timeline on that
um well she said whenever she's ready
it's a secret when she's ready thank you
thank you that's incredible yeah is the
best
um that's it that's it that's all it is
that's all there is
is there anything else you want to talk
about i think you covered a lot i mean
obviously there's
always always more to talk about but you
know
well there'll be more times i'm looking
forward i'd love to include you in some
kind of uh
yeah i was thinking to myself um when
you thought that like
you know everything was over and you
kind of just went away from everything
um i feel like that was so uh far from
the truth
in a way but like
if you ever need a place to do something
you can always
collaborate with us you need if you need
us to announce your only fans we'll do
it
whatever the hell you need why not
that's it that's you guys are so nice
you guys are so
ah thank you i appreciate that
but you know i'm gonna i'm gonna try to
think of a fun segment we could do on
the podcast because i think it would be
it would be great where'd you get that
sword by the way i'm surprised that
thing made it
the sword you sent this you know you
know those um
videos of those like guys cutting
through water bottles
like promoting it yeah yeah it's from
them but that thing is
so not wait cold steel yes it is
what yeah that's a cold steel sword
yeah oh my gosh that thing is so
dull i felt like yeah there's no way
i thought you got like wait uh
that like a thousand bucks that sword or
something crazy no they're not a
thousand no they're super expensive the
cold steel they
they're kind of it was kind of expensive
yeah the cold steels are pricey though
really yeah that's real weaponry dude
cold steel
damn it taking the butt steak and that
thing's not gonna cut through a steak
though
but it's those people right that was
with the steak in the book guys yeah
i thought it was really sharp was it not
sure
no it was super dull i i i have to admit
i did play with it before i
wrapped it up okay so i was like like
cutting through like space it's really
heavy yeah
they're super big yeah well i
love the sword i've used it in tick
tocks and baba bowie to you
and the anime wifey pillow amazing yeah
you just need a fedora right yeah i had
the
that's right i was missing the fedora
well i blame you for not sending it
i'm sorry you should have thought all
right
destroy everything i'm burning it
well belle thank you for coming on it
was great to
chat and get to know you yeah and i
think you're terrific and we're all
fans here at the hd podcast and i look
forward to talking to you again
thank you thank you so much for having
me and thank you everyone else that's
here as well love you all too
all righty thank you for coming on